la statue d'un angelot dans le ciel
hivernal de versailles une sculpture
déplacés du sommet de la chapelle royale
du château une opération à l'aide d'une
grue de 70 mètres de haut dans le cadre
de la restauration de ce bâtiment
historique
un chantier lancé il ya un peu plus de
six mois c'est un moment très émouvant
parce que c'est d'abord très délicat
comme opérations et puis ces groupes
vont partir en restauration
pour le reste tout ce qui reste sur
place qui va être traité c'est la
maçonnerie la pierre de taille les
sculptures les vitraux les vitraux vont
être déposés également les ossatures
métalliques la charpente et la
couverture
au total trois statues ont été descendus
elles forment la sculpture appelée trois
enfants autour d'un palmier une oeuvre
de guillaume coustous et pierre le
poteau réalisé au début du xviiie siècle
qui va connaître un lifting d'un an dans
un atelier une restauration de temps
premièrement restauration des armatures
internes justement avait remplacement de
ces armatures en trop altérés puisqu'on
est en présence de statut en plomb qui
sont creuses dons pour pouvoir les
maintenir en place il faut qu'ils aient
des structures internes métalliques dont
nous allons restaurer ses structures
internes ou les remplacer le coach herbe
et ensuite restauration d'épiderme du
plomb le chantier de la chapelle royale
ne fait que commencer
coût global de cette restauration 16
millions d'euros financé par des mécènes
les travaux devraient être finalisées
d'ici trois ans